okay
dear friend good morning and warm
welcome to Zagreb to the Croatian
national and University library we are
very pleased to host you and honored at
the beginning of the Croatian
presidency of the Council of the
European Union I greet and welcome all
Sola on the line and the entire college
of the European Commission as well as
all the members of the Croatian
government who are here today at the
outset of our meeting we would like to
show you an official video of the
Croatian presidency of the council and
then we will start with the introductory
remarks by myself and Orsola and after
my remarks and a few initial comments
from by Orsola I would kindly ask the
media to to leave us for the in-camera
meeting after that if I could ask my
colleagues to let the video be shown
please
[Music]
CHM separately lien a rope yachts casa
minha groovey Mauro
[Music]
Holly rattles Massa coochie
in ash wood tech Puccini
[Music]
Spillman intrepid brewery cada morena
roster to a layman plan kokubunji edema
is not that conical a Tesla
[Music]
sparkies is of Eureka
the bhisma bill is Prem is a Buddhist
Dharma technolog you
in avati the team quite a deep red
forest forest no poetic swagger yellow
bow
[Music]
now construe the errata lism so of the
nidito vinaigrette
otally small beaten
[Music]
postal is monitored of in Aleppo is a
nice LMC you agree the opposite
[Music]
perversities s problem partner Emma
formaggio posts and Celia
possible orchestra mr. khuswaha
[Music]
mamma jamma yarn etrog EEMA Zionist more
Sigourney
/ okay Terada brother
ala mr. Adama human must not a new tier
as legit of true
starchy odd cat vomit cause le Kony's
[Music]
we're of skewness is for poor SME much
pop agnostic about the course Willis v8
[Music]
cotton cycling Gilmore xenophobia GMO
its Lima Papa Toby tell you this more
Alaska we smell ropa snatch our oppa is
here to Pune Mississauga
[Music]
[Applause]
well I just wondered why watching while
watching this official film should I
have the introductory speech or not
because all the key messages of our
political priorities in our presidency
are actually included in this film that
little bit explains our historical
context our evolution our ambitions and
our desire to by working with all of you
creating stronger and better Europe for
our citizens in our countries madam
president vice president's commissioners
dear colleagues I think that this
meeting of the college and the Croatian
government is not only a historic one
but it should create a conducive
atmosphere for our relationship in the
next six months in various formations of
the council in working jointly on
various legislative doses in our
political consultations because the
challenges ahead about ahead of us at
the beginning of the institution on a
legislative cycle are really many we
have worked on our priorities by looking
carefully at the strategic agenda
adopted by the European Council in June
by fully absorbing the agenda for Europe
that you also have presented to the
European Parliament for which you gained
really a substantial and overwhelming
support of the majority in European
Parliament and we wanted to fit with our
priorities in the general line of the
activities of the European Union that's
why our motto as you have seen has been
a strong Europe in a world of challenges
we have divided our priorities into four
pillars Europe the developed Europe that
connects Europe that protects an
influential Europe when we speak about
the Europe that develops our first
priority is to advocate for a balanced
sustainable and inclusive development
and competitive European Union that
takes into consideration the state of
play in every single Member State
in every single region and most of all
takes into account the desires and
ambitions of our citizens we have put
forward one item which is important for
Croatia and that is the demographic
challenges we know it is not a unique
issue for Croatia it is something that
literally half of the EU member states
face that's why we are very pleased that
dubravka has this portfolio in your
commission I think it's a novelty and we
know that with work ahead of you I think
we can come up with kit of tools proved
to be efficient in those member states
who have addressed the issue of
demographic revitol is Asian adequately
and help us a little bit to see how the
depopulation from rural or movement to
urban areas or from less developed to
more developed member states can be
jointly addressed
also we need within this priority we
want to support your efforts on the
European Green Deal and the very
ambitious legislative agenda which you
have put forward I said yesterday not in
your first hundred days but literally
within your first ten days you are
setting the new standards which will be
very difficult to match for any
executive institution a second priority
Europe that connects is an area where we
want to promote more cooperation in
transport in energy in digital activity
in use of new technologies in going in
the line with the trends of the fourth
Industrial Revolution we also encourage
all those policies which are closer to
citizens through culture education
sports you have seen in the film that
Croatian city of Rijeka will be the
European Capital of Culture it is an
important coin Sinan's but it is also a
convergence of our ambitions in our
presentation to the Europe during this
year and therefore I'm sure you all
enjoyed the concert yesterday in the
Croatian National Theatre Europe that
protects is one of those topics that has
become extremely important over the last
couple of years
both internally and externally we have
faced terrorist attacks we have faced
the challenges of illegal migration we
have seen attacks on our digital
infrastructure by hybrid threats by
influencing from outside and the
democratic processes that's why I think
we need to strengthen the concept of the
rule of law and work together how to
ensure that our citizens are safe and
well off within the European Union
a fourth Opik is an influential Europe
something that we will discuss
immediately as the first item under the
agenda of global I think we all
understand what are the challenges today
even in most recent days literally in
last couple of days with the situation
in Iraq and Iran but we here also want
to extend our hand and show the goodwill
to the countries in the region of
Croatia in the Western Balkans Southeast
Europe that why it literally in this
room we will organize a summit in May
just before the Europe Day that 20 years
after the first Zagreb summit will
reinforce the European perspective at
the dynamics of the future path of our
neighbors towards the European Union we
will work together with you on
completing the negotiations on the
multi-annual financial framework January
will be dedicated to conclusion of
brexit and we hope the tolerate in
February we will have a new negotiating
framework for the future relations the
period of transition is short to
conclude the agreement but we will do
our utmost to work on it and provide a
contribution conference on the future of
Europe will be a subject over lunch I
think it is a necessary initiative now
that the UK will actually finally leave
that we all contemplate and reflect how
we can make our European project more
efficient and how we can regenerate
enthusiasm about its added value to our
development and to our citizens
the final remark that I have is the
you will in Croatian government have a
reliable partner we will work hard with
you in trial logs with European
Parliament notably on the almost 40
legislative pieces of legislation that
accompanies the MFF many of them already
in the pipeline the ministers and their
colleagues have been preparing for this
exercise and this responsibility
throughout our mandate we are now in the
fourth year in the most mature phase and
I think you can count on Croatia just as
we decided to build this part of the
national in university library a part of
Congress and conference center which
will stay here for the purposes of the
city of Zagreb of Croatia also in the
future as a monument and the legacy of
our presidency I thank you all very much
and I would kindly ask you Sola to make
some opening remarks please thank you
very much Andre ministers vice
presidents commissioners it's a pleasure
to be here and thank you very much for
being so wonderful hosts we had a
splendid evening yesterday in the
concert hall and theatre with many
compositions from all over Europe that
showed the richness of European music
and today to be here in the National
Library is a very special moment too I
had the opportunity to see an ancient
missile when I entered here of the
library and I was told it was one of the
first ones that was not written in Latin
but in the origins of your language and
I think it's kind of symbolic because
this step of having a printed book it
was like 20 or 30 years after Gutenberg
the first printing of a book it's the
very first step to transparency is the
very first step to enlightenment which
is both or are both the foundation of
creating democracies
and sitting here together in this group
shows the strength of democracy over
time over centuries and then decades and
thank you very much for receiving us
here and showing us the richness of your
heritage
indeed you mentioned topics we're going
to discuss today this is the first
creation presidency but for us it comes
at a very crucial moment because it is
at the beginning of our mandate so your
success will also define our success and
I've carefully listened again to the
priorities we said I can only say your
priorities are also our priorities
indeed we will today discuss the broader
context of a influential Europe and you
mentioned the topics we will speak about
brexit we have to define the room which
includes old friends but new beginnings
with our British friends we will work
for the strategy with Africa together
with your presidency we will be
preparing the EU China summit so this
shows already the topics ahead of us but
we will also as you mentioned look at
our neighbours immediate neighbours
mainly under the component of
enlargement and here we count on your
experience Croatia is